Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Portal 2 with Shodleech also known as Patrick
Say hi.
- Hellooooo
Ok, so we were overthinking this,
or I specifically was overthinking this.
LE.. UNLEASH THE BEAST!
*Smash*
Oww!
Why?
*giggles*
What did you even do?
I didn't do anything. (Laughing Slightly)
I didn't even move!
Something happened, ok.
UNLEASH THE BEAST! (Awkward Silence)
Aaany day now.
The beast unleashed.
Noooo!
Again.
Again, you're doing it on purpose. I know for a fact you are doing it on purpose and it's not cool.
In the beginning I wasn't, now I am.
Ok, unleash the beast.
Aha. Ok, so the overthinking was.
We both didn't need to be up here right away, because there is a portable wall right there. Come on up.
Boink.
- Yeah, that's why i asked earlier if there was one..
budududududah
I was- I was using my genius brain.
My genius brain was too strong.
Which costed us 10 minutes.
Ooh hush your face, 10 minutes isn't that valuable.
You wanna know how much time I've wasted on playing video games? It's A LOT.
A whole lot.
Yeah.
So anyway.
So we're back and again. Whoa.
That looks weird.
What the hell.
So are you gonna be on the top
and I'm gonna be on the bottom ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°). Whoa.
Oh boy.
- What is going on here?
I don't think I wanna know.
Wow.
- Oooh no.
Alright, I'm gonna press the button.
Ooooh, ohh, it's, ooooh, ooh, that's cool.
I get to see the entire thing on here.
Does that mean i have to run to every single button, before the ball gets to there?
I don't know. Maybe. You don't know.
Is there even a ball or is it just us,
trying to make you go through?
Ummmmmmmm.
I'm not gonna make any assumptions about what it may or may not be, until I have a better idea of what I'm doing
Which.
Apparently is nothing.
Well the first question is, is there a ball button?
There is not
One of these might be a ball button but, the more important thing is, we need to coordinate.
Because, you control some of these, and then
I control some of these, so.
I'm assuming, I'm just assuming, that the end and start paths are here.
I'm pressing the end signed button.
Ok.
Ok, so that didn't work obviously but ok, so this is the IN portal and this is the OUT one.
So we need to get this to go to that.
Well there is a ball, I saw a ball.
- Yes there is a ball, it comes out of this one.
So you need to push the button below this one, that button, you need to push that.
And I need to push this one.
And then we line this up, so just follow this track.
And eventually, we will get to where we need to go.
So now this one needs to be pushed.
Ok, following thiks way.
doinkdedoinkdedonink
Connecting, connecting, connecting (x3)
Ok, that connects, push the ball button.
See if that ball will go.
See where it goes.
Fiiiiire!
Fire in the hole.
Ok, it's rolling, it's rolling, it's going.
Yes, connecting good.
Velocity is stable, pressure is high.
Everything is going good.
My butt is tingling.
Aaand kabooski.
Where did it go?
Ooh.
Hang on i just saw it, it appeared over here.
Well hot diggity, we did it.
That was easy.
And that was our first try, other than when i first pressed the button.
Yeah, not bad, ok. Kaboink.
Oh.
Alright.
Ok.
Cool.
- Cake?
Cake?
Just let the cake meme die. (never)
You don't need to do anything with cake.
Alright, come back down here.
Seriously, that joke is literally older than I am. You will get nothing but hate on the internet if you mention cake! )
And nobody in the comments mention cake! (mention cake :3)
Observe the juggling balls, of glory.
Nice, very nice and then come this way.
You're doing great. You're doing good so far.
Oooh look, we're done.
We did it :D
Tadaaa.
Not bad, we finished one of the community levels, so hopefully we're gonna get another one after this.
And then everything is.. *Screaming* Soo much pain!!!
*A bit more screaming* Ok.
Alright boink. Ow, my grundle.
Ok sooo, what a we got. Uh oh, well that don't look good.
Ok.
- You first.
Allright, i'll go first cause i'm the brave one.
This goes here, this goes here.
Walk through the portal.
Wait. I'm gonna die.
- Walk through. *girly scream of fear*
Hahaha, see jokes on you. You thought you were gonna die, but the answer was we're not.
Well that doesn't look good.
Ow.
Well. That's a lot of death.
- Told ya'.
Well, what are you talking about, you died too,
you're not any better off.
I said, i'm gonna die.
And I died.
Oh, ok. Well, honesty is the best policy.
Ok.
So somehow..
Huh.
So we have to literally time our portals very accurately.
Well, what we need to do is we need to get through there alive.
What we need to do is not get our shit blown to pieces.
That's usually a good policy but not one that I'm gonna take at this moment
Cause I... Have a strategy.
And it involves speeding quickly through here so we don't get shot... to pieces.
Okay.
- Okay.
*Screaming*
Nope no no okay it's not gonna work.
That is.. the wrong strategy.
But the right strategy...
Is...
Um...
As follows...
- Survival.
No no. I got it. Okay. I got it. I got i- Hush.
Hush your.. beautiful face.
Bam!
See, we need to go down here first,
before we can do anything.
Want me to bring you down here, or should I stay up here?
Uuuumm... Let meee... see what the sitch is first. Okay.
So.
You can come down here I think.
Okay.
So, it looks like...
To my death. *Shodleech explodes*
Why did you miss?!
*Chuckles* A really interesting question to ask.
*Markiplier mocking himself* Why'd you miss?!
Okay.
I just missed?
Okay so...
That doesn't help anybody.
Let's see... But that...
Does that help anybody?
That does not.
That helps nobody no one.
- I still feel like...
There's that one white wall up there still.
Which is what I'm thinking-
- Where? Point to it!
Point to it!
Where do you see it? Oh I see something.
I'm tryin' to, but it's not letting me.
I know what.
Goodbye! I must go to my people!
Ah, schiiiiiiiit
But I know- I know what. I know what. Okay.
- Yeah, go to your people.
I'm going to- goodbye. Goodbye cruel world. Goodbye.
Goodbyyyyyeee!
- Goodbye.
I know what to do. I know it. I know what to do. I got it.
Brainwaves here out the wazoo. You're gonna see. You're gonna be so proud of me.
You ready to be proud?
Yes.
You ready to be P-R-O-D proud?
Okay.
Bang!
And..?
Uuuuuuuuhhhh...
Clearly, that wall that you were just at was the one I was talking about.
SHH! SHH! SHH!
*Whispers loudly* It's okay.
I know. My genius is intimidating.
It is
-Okay so we gotta find a way
to go through there...
Up there. Do you see where I put it? Do you see that?
I see... Yeah.
Do you see the power of my genius?
Hop! Okay, miss that.
Okay, this is gonna kill me.
I'm going to die.
Okay goodbye! *boom* I died.
Alright. But. Thaaaat...
Where do I got to put my portals at?